I want to talk to you today
about using Deadline along
with the Google Cloud platform.
I'll start off with an
overview of Deadline.
It was developed to
allow render farm
to be shared between
applications, departments,
and of course, between
facilities as well.
It's been used by large
and small companies
alike around the world.
It does not use a
single manager design
it's meant to be distributed.
Instead the slave logic
that is built into the line
picks up the work
based on the set
of rules, the criteria,
and scheduling logic
that you provide.
Right now deadlines supports or
70 applications out of the box,
and can be added via Python
and the native applications
scripting languages.
Deadline was meant
to be artist driven.
We want it to be really
easy, one click to install.
We want it to be able to render,
simulate, execute commands, do
software builds.
We actually use
internally at Thinkbox.
Do out own software builds.
And of course we have extensive
public and private file
support, which I'm here
to talk about today.
We want you to have the
best of both worlds,
use your existing
infrastructure,
your existing Deadline's
set up, your local hardware,
plus use on demand.
And the best way to do that of
course, Google Cloud Platform.
We have extensive support
for Google Cloud Platform.
The way we do that is with
the new module in Deadline,
called the virtual
machine extension.
It's able to launch and
terminate virtual machines.
We can do it through
a cloud panel
or we can do in an automated
way through a program called
Bouncer, I'll tell you a
little bit about that as we go.
And we have a sort of
fancy Cloud installer
if you want to get
going on the Cloud
very quickly with
the Cloud repository,
you can use our Cloud
wizard to do that.
These are the sort of
common Deadline components.
I'm going to spend
a lot of time here,
but the short version
is the repository
in the database form the queue.
And the key worker
applications is
Slave, that's responsible
for controlling
my max nuke whatever, doing the
actual rendering on the render
node.
There's various
support applications.
Pulse monitors your
interface into the queue,
Draft for lightweight
compositing,
and of course you
licensed server.
Let's talk about the
Cloud-related components
of Deadline.
Deadline Balancer
is the mechanism
that we have for doing
automated launching
and terminating
virtual machines.
I'll talk about that in
a little bit more detail.
We have an Asset Crawler
script essentially
that sits on each Cloud region
that you enable and watches
for assets and makes sure
that jobs don't try to render
before the assets are ready.
On the Google side,
of course you're
going to a Google Cloud account.
That's your own personal
account or company account,
depending on how
you're using it.
A virtual network
within the Cloud,
this is sort of a little bubble
within your Cloud account
where you build a network
to do the rendering.
Virtual private network
forms the bridge
between your local facility
and your Cloud account
for secure communications.
Storage on the Cloud.
And then you'll also need the
virtual machines themselves
that have the information
for the operating
system, the worker application
like my Deadline slate
and so forth.
Those are the
components and I'll
start to talk a little bit
about how it all fits together.
We sort of promote a
hybridized approach.
We call it Pop-up Cloud as
our sort of buzzword for that.
We combine local compute
resources will off
site private or public
Cloud resources.
You have a local office and
the VPN that connects you up
to your Cloud.
This is enabled through
our Cloud provider dialogue
within Deadline.
This is where you can add Cloud
regions from your provider
and configure all
the credentials
and so forth so that
once it's configured
Deadline can talk to the
Cloud and get things done.
Let me tell you about
some of the ways
that Deadline can be configured.
It's meant to be
extremely flexible.
And so sometimes people ask
me, how should we set this up?
It really depends
on your use case,
there's a lot of different
ways you can do it.
The various
components of Deadline
can be installed in different
locations, it's very tolerant.
As long as the pieces
could talk to each other
they can pretty
much exist anywhere.
In this particular configuration
for direct submission
the database and repository
are up in the Cloud.
You've got the balancer
application up in the Cloud,
it's starting and
stopping virtual machines.
You've got some Cloud storage.
On your local side you
probably have an artist,
you might have a couple of
slaves running locally as well,
it'd be driven by that
Cloud based repository,
and got your local file store.
One possible configuration.
Another possible configuration.
Move the database and
repository locally.
Essentially the
same, the balancer
might be local in
that case as well,
or it could be, again,
up in the Cloud.
But still you're talking
to a set of cloud slaves
and a set of local
slaves, you've
got your local storage,
your cloud storage.
And you have that flexibility
again of your local system
and your Cloud system.
And then a third
configuration could be
that you have two repositories.
Some of the companies that we
work with really like to you
might say micromanage
their Cloud rendering.
And so what they
do is they set up
an entirely separate repository,
basically a separate render
farm, in the Cloud, they got
their own local render farm.
And a lot of times
this happens simply
because they have a local farm
that's all working perfectly,
they want to play
with this stuff,
they want to do it
carefully, so they'll set up
a separate farm in the Cloud.
Once they get their
head around it
they'll probably move back to
one of the other configurations
where there's only
a single repository.
But again, it's quite seamless.
You can use whichever
configuration works for you.
The mechanism that we use
to decide whether a job can
go to the Cloud or not
is called Group Mappings,
this is the interface for it.
Let me talk more conceptually
about how it works.
Deadline has a notion of groups.
Whenever you submit
a job to Deadline,
you submit it to a group.
The group can be sort
of anything you define.
Quite often you'll
see a configuration
like 3D simulation, I'm
looking at the column sort
of in the middle that
says Group Mapping,
you have a 3D group,
a simulation group,
a proxy group, a composite.
This could be whatever you want.
On the left side is your queue.
This is sort of a schematic
representation of a queue,
there might be a Maya
job in there, a draft job
for doing proxy and Bifrost.
Each of these jobs
has a group that
is associated with the
job when it's submitted.
So what the Group Mapping does,
is it says, OK, for this group,
let's look at for example
3D at the top there,
I want to map that group to an
N1 standard for instance, four
core instance, and I want to
map it into a virtual machine
image that has Deadline
Slave installed,
it's got Maya it's got Max.
Basically all the three
software, plus Deadlines
control software.
And what will happen then, is
that basically tells Deadline
that the 3D group is
enabled within this region,
and these settings
are on a per region
basis, so if you have
multiple regions set up
you can actually control
which sort of hardware
and which VM images
that you use.
At the bottom you'll
notice that, for example
the composite group
doesn't have a mapping,
and all this is saying is that
for this particular region
we don't want the job
going to the Cloud,
we'll just keep those locally.
So you have the-- can have a
job go to multiple regions, one
region, it all just depends
on the group mapping
so that you have a lot of
flexibility and control
of that.
Once your group
mappings are defined
and Deadline knows the job
is eligible to be processed
on the Cloud, the
program that will do that
is called Balancer.
And Balancer basically
watches over the queue
and it says OK I see some
jobs and I see some mappings,
and so based on the
demand and based
on all of your configuration
settings and your budget,
I'm going to start up
some instances over here
or terminate some instances
over there and so forth.
So, launching and terminating
virtual machine instances
by hand would be tedious.
You could manually
launch them but it's not
going to be
efficient, so this is
an automated way of doing that.
Saves costs with regard
to starting and stopping
virtual machines.
And it will balance
across regions.
And the algorithm
that decides which
virtual machines get started and
when and all that is pluggable.
So we provide a
default algorithm
that we feel pretty
efficient, but we
realize that studios
may want to hook
into other things you may want
to provide sort of deep status
controls.
So the algorithm's pluggable,
you can look at the code
that we provide and modify
it, copy it, make your own.
Come talk to us if you need
help, we're happy to help you.
Deadline, this is the
settings for Balancer
for a given region.
One of the key
things look at there
is that green box in the
middle, that's the budget.
What the budget does
is it makes sure
that you don't exceed a certain
spend rate within that region.
That could be dollars per hour
or whatever units you want,
typically is dollars per hour.
And the reason for that is
that because the algorithm is
pluggable, it's sometimes
possible to make a mistake,
as what happens with
any computer code.
So the Balancer will
always make sure
that, no matter what
the algorithm says
in terms of starting
virtual machines,
it may say start 500
million virtual machines,
the Balancer will say what your
budget just doesn't support
that, so we're going to
clamp it your actual request
to fit within your budget.
So sort of a safety mechanism.
And it also let's you
control your overall spend
for project as well.
Deadline has, in
its current form,
something we call
asset awareness.
At present we don't do
automated asset management,
but we have a lot
of controls in there
to make sure that things
don't actually render
until your assets are ready.
So, for example,
the jobs haven't
required asset property,
and when that's populated
it says which assets are
required to process a job.
The asset crawler
lives on the Cloud,
and it keeps an eye on which
assets are up on the Cloud.
And the Balancer then we'll
talk to that Asset Crawler
and say, hey, do you have
the assets for this job?
And if the Asset
Crawler says yes,
then the Balancer will green
light that job for the Cloud.
If it doesn't then Balancer
will just discount that job.
And then finally the job will
be green lit for the Cloud,
but again it won't pick up
unless those assets are ready.
So this prevents errors,
prevents waste and spend.
So this is all fine and good.
Is great that you can configure
deadline in all these ways,
you can do all
this stuff with it.
But there's a little bit
of learning curve there.
And so we want to help you
get started and with this as
quickly as possible so that you
can get your head around it.
We do that was something called
the Deadline Cloud Wizard.
What it does is it does an
automated set up of the pieces
and you need to get a Cloud
Based repository render
farm going.
Installs VPN, configures
Cloud storage,
installs temporary Deadline
and Balancer licensing,
int installs a fully functional
repository and database,
it downloads example VM
images preconfigured with,
for example Maya
and Blender things
like that so you
can see it work.
It pre-populates the queue
with some example jobs,
you can basically see
the whole thing work out
of your own account
very quickly.
So I have a video this is a
sort of a edited down video
of actually running
the Cloud Wizard.
So you download the
Cloud Wizard from us,
install it on your
machine and fire it up.
We're going to set up a Cloud
based farm right in front you.
There's a few prerequisites
you need to do.
Obviously you need to set up
your Google Cloud account,
you need to create a project,
and you enable the Google
Compute Engine.
These things just
take a few minutes.
So hear are the
project IDs going in.
I'm getting the OAuth
credentials, which
allows the Cloud Wizard to
talk to your Cloud account,
to talk to Google, and take
action to install things,
to do things.
So this is basically setting
up the authentication.
And it is good.
So there.
Authentication completed.
The next thing it's going to
do is set up some SSH keys.
It can be done
automatically for you.
I mentioned that you need
a little mini network
inside of your Cloud
account, so it's
going to set that up for you.
Retrieving temporary licensing.
It's going to copy
the virtual machine
images for
infrastructure, that means
the repository, your
database, your licensing,
as well as the demo instances.
It's setting up a
VPN firewall rules,
it's launching the
infrastructural VN
so that your repository and
database are coming online.
And It's telling
you to shut down
any VPN you might already
have going because it's
going to set up it's own.
Go and do that right now.
And once that's up and
running then pretty much
you have a secure connection
between your local workstation
and your Cloud account.
Finish up in a moment,
and license server set up
is done now that it
has the Mac address
and has installed the licensing.
It's now doing the last
minute configuration
on the repository.
You can imagine doing this
by hand would take a while,
so the whole idea of
the direction that we're
going with all of this is to
make it happen automatically,
quickly for you, basically
again pop-up Cloud.
So, here the Balancer
application is launched.
This is a brand new
repository so it's creating
an account for me on Deadline.
Here is Monitor, with a couple
of jobs in the upper left hand
corner.
I'm going to switch
into super user mode,
and go back to configure
Cloud providers.
Here we can see the
Google Cloud region that
was set up automatically
by the Cloud Wizard
all the credentials
have been entered
based on what you put
into the Cloud Wizard
so you don't have to
go through all that.
Lots of settings and saves
time, Balancer options,
initial budget set to two,
just to keep it nice and safe
for testing and play.
These are the group mappings,
I talked about earlier.
If we look at, for
example, the Blender group
we can see that it's been
set to n1-standard-1,
one core instance type,
and it's using the image
that has Blender installed.
So when a Blender
job is ready to go,
which I'm about to do
right here by resuming
both of these jobs,
both Maya and Blender,
it will start those up.
Now one of those jobs, I didn't
actually-- you can't really
see the priority of the
jobs here, but one of them
has a little bit more
priority than the other.
Balancer will
recognize that and try
to populate virtual
machines for that job first.
And we can see it
populating the state.
It's running through
the algorithm,
the pluggable algorithm,
which tells it,
hey, we need a couple of
virtual machines fired up
for Maya because that's what our
budget said that we could do.
And then it starts firing
up virtual machines.
And if I wanted to
go back and say well,
two isn't really enough
let's bump it up to 10.
Get things done a
little bit faster.
And trust me the
numbers can get bigger,
I'll talk about that later.
And within a few moments, within
the next cycle of the bouncer,
again this is a
bit time compressed
because the amount of time that
we have for the presentation.
But it will
recognize that change
and say oh you've
got more budget now,
so let's fire up
some additional VMs.
As the Maya job
completes, it will then
go down to the job that
has next highest priority,
will start shutting down
the Maya virtual machines
and spinning up the
Blender virtual machines
because that's what's needed.
It will also recognize, if
you have two different job
types that are using the exact
same virtual machine images,
it will just switch over
to those intelligently.
It wont shut things down
start them back up again.
So there's a lot of choice
of configuration here, we've
tried to keep it as flexible
as possible, and yet as
easy as possible.
So now the Maya job's
done, firing up Blender,
we're seeing virtual
machines fire up for that
through the Balancer.
So that's pretty much
it for the Cloud Wizard,
in terms of watching
demo of it run,
I think I'm just going to
skip forward at this point.
It's going to essentially
finish that job
and then terminate
those virtual machines.
So, quick recap on
the Cloud Wizard.
It only usually takes
about 30 minutes
to run in most of our testing.
There's a little
bit of prerequisite,
like I said, that stuff
shouldn't really take you
more than 15 to 30 minutes.
So I'd say in under
an hour you can
be playing with the
Cloud render farm that's
running in your own account.
Thinkbox helps you out
with a 30 day evaluation,
so there's no cost on the
Thinkbox side to try this out.
Google's kind enough
to help you out
with a $500 credit for
your Cloud compute time.
That means essentially
that you can
get started with this
at no cost to you,
the only real cost is your time.
So figure couple
hours for that and you
can actually play with this, get
your head around the concepts,
and think about how you might
want to do your implementation.
Does it scale?
You can see the number
on the left the middle?
No?
Make a bigger.
5,000 instances we've
tested for sure,
we didn't come close to
tapping out what system can do.
I'm quite certain that we could
reach many, many multiples
of that number.
I seriously doubt most
studios will need that many,
but if you do, give us
a call or give Google
a call I'm sure we'll
very happy to talk to you.
What's coming next?
I'd mentioned the Deadline
has asset awareness right now
but it doesn't really
manage assets for you.
We are all over that,
we have some prototypes
that we showed at NAB.
We're building a comprehensive
system for asset management
that's coming very
soon, if you want
to get on the beta
for that I'll tell you
how to do that real soon.
Simplified connectivity,
I mentioned
the virtual private network
that you need to set up.
A lot of studios will
probably still want
a virtual private
network, but we're
going to come up with
a proxy server that
will eliminate the need for
a VPN and still be secure,
as an alternative if
you want to go that way.
Big news, we are right
on the brink of a beta
testing on demand licensing.
So the Deadline
licensing can match
the kind of licensing
that you see with services
like Google Cloud Platform.
Per minute, per hour,
monthly billing models.
It works additively
so if you already
have permanent licenses you
can just extend beyond them
with the on demand licensing.
We're making the system
available to third party
vendors so that smaller
plug-in developers and so forth
can piggyback on the system
and get on demand licensing
as well.
As I said, beta testing is
starting pretty much right
away, so give us a shout
if you want to try this.
That's pretty much it.
Thinkbox is building progressive
and hybridized workflows
targeting end users with
no development experience.
But also remaining
extremely flexible
and configurable for
very large studios.
We have several very big
name, very large studios that
are deploying this kind
of set up right now,
and you'll be hearing
more about that very soon.
It's our belief that
on demand extensions
to existing infrastructure
is the right way to go.
With that said, there's
lots of different ways
we've seen lots of different
solutions here, all of them
are valid, all of
them provide value.
And so we have our
philosophy as well,
and it is to extend your
existing system with on demand.
And that's it.
Here's some links
for more information.
The easiest way to
contact us is just
go to thinkboxsoftware.com.
That's misspelled, I just
noticed that the top, sorry.
I There's my email address,
some YouTube videos,
a link to the Cloud
Wizard, and of course,
the beta testing link,
and lots of people Google
who've been absolutely fantastic
helping us with our API
integration credits
and so forth,
to make Deadline absolutely
rock solid on Google.
And we really look forward
to hearing from you
and, like I said try it
out, there's no cost.
You can do in a very short
amount of time play with it
and see how it works.
Thanks.